[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside live
moods live
welcome back what are you thinking about
these matchups today
well i they're not my favorite matchups
to be honest with you but nba is back so
i can't complain the all-star break was
nice but i was missing some hoops for
sure so i'm excited to get back into it
definitely was missing some hoops
speaking on behalf of a lot of the
betters we were all missing the hoops uh
nba hoops i'm sorry not because college
basketball was still there but nba hoops
but as always we're giving away locks
we're giving away hoodies and we are
giving away jersey so get in those
comments we need gifts we need emojis
but most importantly liv we need
winners only please
there it is there it is i'm gonna give
away a jersey right now
if you guys don't know now you guys know
this right here is the handy dandy
iphone and this is how you are getting
your hoodies today
uh i'm in the comments i see maxwell
rexella in the comments shout out to you
maxo rexel he said he is taking the
warrior spread today shout out to you uh
all right i'm back in the i see go
garden in the comments go guardian in
the common sense best show i'm riding
with my bulls love the swag live
go garden you are walking away with a
jersey of your choice all right liv it's
tnt basketball thursday which means
we are betting the three by two the
question is will there be two three
pointers in the first
three minutes of the game today we are
running back the three by two parlay
it's the brooklyn nets taking on the
boston celtics and we have the portland
show blazers taking on those golden
state warriors live this one is boosted
up
from plus 230 to plus 300. the question
is will there be two or more
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes
of each of those games get in the
comments and tell us if you are riding
live talk to us
what are you thinking
uh i'm thinking it's gonna be a sweat uh
the celtics nets and warriors all ranked
top ten in perimeter defense so we're
gonna be sweating this one out i am
definitely nervous about it our saving
grace though is that the nets are out a
lot of starters their perimeter defense
may be lacking and the trailblazers rank
bottom two in perimeter defense so all
i've got to say is let's go celtics and
let's go warriors
let's go celtics let's go warriors uh
i'm in the comments right now i'm in the
comments giving away hoodies
i see f x f hx1 fhs1 my man manual says
yes sir it is a lock is rocking with a
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie easy defeat also says yes
shout out to you easy defeat uh you are
walking away with the hoodie live the
comments are jumping and you know i like
to give away hoodies i'll give out one
more i'll give out one more we got uh
mike epps and seth curley seth curry is
dropping dimes today everybody
we are riding the three by two part lay
like liv said we will be sweating but
that is okay because we are riding
together as a family now it's time for
my favorite part of the show live let's
talk major markets money lines against
the sprint and point totals for
tonight's game let's take a look at the
odds live what are you seeing here and
what do you like
yeah i mean i i rarely take unders just
because they stress me out but i'm
liking under 214 and a half in this
boston brooklyn game this boston defense
is third in terms of points allowed to
their opponent and 57.6 of their games
this season have gone under brooklyn is
out many starters so like i said i'm not
sure offensively what they're gonna
bring to the table in this game in terms
of scoring they're also only averaging
105.5 points per game in the last 10
matchups i don't really see this game
being very close i think we may get a
blowout here from the celtics so i'm
liking the ender in this game
live is rocking with the under okay liv
i see you rocking with the under
i'm gonna do something i usually don't
do and that is fade the golden state
warriors but 10 points live is a lot of
points
everybody's gonna have somewhat sort of
fresh legs coming off of the all-star
game and
10 points that's just a lot this
warriors team they kind of was
struggling before the all-star game
i don't know if they're gonna come out
of the all-star game uh not struggling
so
laying 10 points or having to lay ten
points on the road i'm just going to
fade that so uh i'm rocking with the
portland trailblazers
but i'm in the comments live i'm in the
comments cause i'm here to give away
these hoodies because that's what the
people want and i got hand dog hand dog
23 says boston under
rocking with the boston under live uh
shout out to you hand dog 23 mike bolan
is in the comments my man mike bolan
says steph curry and seth curry will
both help the 3x2 parlay cash tonight
shout out to you mike bowling
uh i got one more in me liv one more jt
for mvp zero says boston moneyline shout
out to you j
p you are walking away what the uh
hoodie all right liv we talked major
markets now let's talk
those player problems it's time for lock
or not i'm gonna put up a prop and i
need all of you to get in the comments
and tell me whether it is a lock or not
let's get right to it the first up is my
man i like to call him 30 you might call
him steph curry
but 30 to make five or more three
pointers sitting at
minus
162 live
talk to me
talk to the people do you like this one
or do you not
yeah i mean the value's not great but i
do think it's a lock the trailblazers uh
as i mentioned earlier struggle with
perimeter defense they rank bottom three
and three-pointers allowed and bottom
three in opponents having the highest
three-point percentage he's also had six
threes in the two games that he's played
versus the trailblazers this season so
unless we see a blowout i don't think
that he should have any problem hitting
this over so i'm gonna say steph curry
from the three tonight is a lot
liv is rocking with steph curry from the
three
and liv
my heart thinks that this is gonna
happen my mind even thinks that this is
gonna happen
but it's sitting at minus 162.
and that is bad value i mean if if if we
were talking anybody else three or more
three-pointers usually is plus money
we're talking about five three-pointers
here and i know this is steph curry i
know this is steph curry i know what he
just did in the all-star game but it's
i just don't know and i'm a steph curry
fan i don't know if i'm willing to put
my money on the minus 162 so i'm gonna
stay
away from that live but
i'ma hop in these comments because i
want to see what they talking about i
want to see what they are coming up with
uh
jr037 says curry is a lock
shout out to you you are walking away
with a hoodie i also see uh
i i also see hold on mike bolan i see
you cain o-matic that's a pop and a lock
he's rocking with steph curry okay let's
move on because we got josh hart
to score 17 plus points live it's
sitting at -106 talk to us do you like
this one or do you not
i actually really do like this one in
the last seven the warriors have allowed
opposing small forwards an average of 22
points per game and since being acquired
by the trailblazers he has scored 20
plus in all three games with his new
team i think he is a much bigger role on
offense with this team especially
tonight so i actually really like this
play a lot i'm gonna say it's a lock
i'm right there with you liv i think
josh roll is trying to uh establish his
role in portland and in order to
establish a role you got to go out there
and make a statement and i think that
that's what he's out there doing you
mentioned over 20 points in his last
three games with his new team he's out
there trying to make a statement
and with that being said i think tonight
he's going to go out there and try to
make a statement against his golden
state warriors team i'm also rocking
with the trailblazers here so i'm
aligning the dots but i do like the 17
points sitting at minus 106. let me hop
into these comments though let me hop
into these comments to see what they are
talking about i got forest cuts forest
cut says oh i like this he's rocking
with us live he likes the josh hart play
i also see jboy5204 says josh hart is a
lock same name as me lock it in
josh we are locking it in for you all
right liv finally
we have kevon looney to have eight or
more rebounds sitting at
minus
235 liv
talk to me talk to the people do you
like this
i i don't i don't i don't really even
like the play but i especially don't
like it sitting at that value um the
trailblazers have actually allowed the
third fewest rebounds to opposing
centers in the last seven and looney has
only hit this in five of the last ten so
like i said i'm not loving the play in
general but especially not at -235 so
i'm gonna say it's not a lock tonight
yeah i'm right there with you liv he
might hit this to be honest he should
hit this is that minus 2 35 but am i
betting it probably not i'm gonna stay
away from this one uh but i'm in the
comments though because they might be
petting it they might sprinkle it uh so
i'ma see what they are talking about in
the comments
oh jones jordan jones jordan says faith
that he's not like that talking about my
man kevin looney whoa whoa whoa kevvan
kat von's like that he's on those golden
slave warriors but i'll give you a
hoodie i will send you a hoodie b wilson
27 says he's saying no we are also
saying no b wilson you are walking away
with a hoodie all right liv it's time to
build
the br betting same
game parlay which you can ride with us
on fanduel tonight
we're looking at the celtics next game i
need everybody and i mean everybody to
get in the comments and tell me what
they think
which legs or locks which legs or not
live are you ready to get right to it
i'm ready let's do it
let's get right to it first up we got
the man jason tatum
to score
25 points or more liv
do you like this one or do you not
well first i gotta say over on the
fanduel sportsbook our friends over at
fanduel are hooking us up with a special
boost in regards to jason tatum so
that's why i'm bringing it up jason
tatum to score 30 plus points and the
celtics to win has been boosted from
plus 190 to plus 250. so if you think
tatum is having a night and you think
the celtics are getting that dub
definitely head over to the fanduel
sports book and sprinkle on that boost
that they so kindly offered for us
tonight uh but in terms of the leg of
the same game parley tatum only averages
17 points in two games against brooklyn
this season however with a lot of real
brooklyn starters out i do think he's in
a better position to score a lot tonight
25 is a lot of points 30 is a lot of
points for that boost but
like i said a lot of starters out for
the net so their defense may be lacking
so he is in a better spot to get some
more points tonight so it's gonna be a
sweat but uh he can get it i think he
can get it done
liv thinks it's gonna be a sweat but she
also thinks that he can get it done so
feeling good about the jayson tatum
points play let's go to the second leg
of the parlay and we're talking about
his teammate jaylen brown
all we need for him to go do is get 20.
do you think he can do that tonight
you know jalen jaylen brown is one of
those players that'll make you sweat on
any given night he's either super hot
one second or he's super not the next i
could sk i could actually see him
scoring right at 20 tonight so i think
again this is gonna be one that we're
kind of sitting on the edge of our seat
for the entire game i do think he's
obviously capable of scoring 20 plus but
i think it's gonna be right around 20
and we're gonna be sweating this one as
well
liv thinks we're gonna sweat this one as
well i think we got a trend here liv
so i guess the next one seth curry are
we sweating this one as well
we need him to get 15 points or more is
this one the sweat lift
actually no i really really like this
leg um although the celtics have been
guarding guards pretty well as of
recently seth curry seems to score well
against the celtics celtics team now he
has been with another team prior to
being with the nets but with so many
players out for the nets i feel like
i've broken record here his offensive
role is even bigger tonight um so i
really like this leg a lot he shoots
well against the celtics team a lot of
starters out for the net so his role is
going to be crucial tonight so i do like
this leg i don't think we're going to
sweat this one as much
all right look we finally got a no
sweater for liv mixed into this parlay
but i'm not gonna lie to you liv i'm
actually sweating this next one you man
patty mills yes at emails
to make three or more three pointers
tonight
talk to me talk to the people
do you like this one or do you not
patty mills has probably given me more
heart attacks than i should ever have in
my lifetime i mean he knows how to keep
me on the edge of my seat and make me
sweat out of bed that is for sure but
similarly to seth in this spot i think
patty definitely has a bigger role
tonight than he normally would with no
kyrie no simmons
no more harden at all and no kd as well
he has shot
61.5 from the three-point line on
average this season when facing the
celtics so he's capable of it he's hit
this over in one of the two games he's
played the celtics this year and in the
game he did hit it he went seven for ten
from the three-point line i think he's
going to take a lot of shots and i think
because his role is even bigger he's
really going to have to hit this and so
he's going to make it a priority so
fingers crossed we're going to be
sweating but i actually think that patty
mills will hit three plus threes tonight
good vibes good vibes from liv all right
let's put up the ticket so i can show
you guys if you guys want to put a
hundred dollars
down
you will be walking away with 380
there it is liv before i get into these
comments what are you grading the same
game parlay
don't get upset people i'm giving this
one a c c still get degrees we're still
passing the class we're still graduating
it's all good but there's a lot of
sweating that we're going to be having
tonight with this parlay i definitely
don't look at this parlay and go oh easy
money we're gonna be sweating this one
out but what's a good cash without a
good sweat so i'm giving it a c we're
still passing but
get ready to sweat get your sweat towels
tonight for sure
everybody go and grab your towels
according to liv we are sweating
tonight but i am in the comments i'm in
the comments because i want to see if
they're rocking with this same game
parlay uh we got rabby rab ravi burke
says
facts are he says lock live stating
facts on paddy shout out to you robbie
burke you are walking away
with a hoodie i'm also giving away a
jersey here liv i'm giving away a jersey
and i see uh
i see forest cuts back it says
definitely a sea lift shout out to you
for it's because jones jordan is back
today is seth and steph knight i i do
agree jay hearn says i'm gonna give this
parliament
tatum will score a lot of points
and he and brown will have their way
tonight versus the depleted nets they
will easily put up the buckets and
that's what they do 15 for seth is easy
especially since everyone is out he will
have to shoot a lot patty is one of the
best shooters in the league and this is
a lock imma go throw down on this one
love the hoodies by the way fresh
jay hearn knows what to do
so shout out to you jay hearn i'm
sending you a hoodie and i'ma send you a
jersey live
all-star weekend is in the books let's
talk futures for a minute now you just
got back from all-star weekend
in fact but today we asked you in the
app which team is most likely to win
the nba title this season
let's take a look at the updated odds
live you see the numbers what are you
thinking here
yeah not the nets uh i'll start there i
know we've got a little kevin durant
picture there and brooklyn sitting at
plus 550 but not the nets i think their
lack of chemistry this year is gonna
stand in their way i mean you've got
kyrie who can't play every game james
harden to me was the most consistent
player on the court he's gone kd has
been battling injury and i don't think a
guy like ben simmons is the answer to a
chemistry problem and that's just how i
feel about that so i actually like the
76ers better coming out of the east than
i do the nets i'm really excited to see
this hardened embiid combo obviously
embiid is playing mvp uh basketball
right now he's the favorite and uh i'm
excited to see what hardin can do to
help him win more games so i like the
76ers the best out of the east right now
as for the west
my hot take of the year is that the suns
are going to choke we're seeing now that
chris paul is out six to eight weeks so
i'm very intrigued to see how they do
without him uh that may have been of
that that might have been what my gut
was telling me all season was that
something down the stretch was going to
happen and it was going to affect the
sun's team uh nonetheless i think right
now the best play is the warriors i've
got them coming out of the west i think
once green is healthy they're going to
be back in business and back to where
they were earlier in the season so i say
i say the warriors right now is my best
bet
liv
i'm right there with you we are locked
uh in step in picks uh i i i i been
saying the warriors from the beginning
you've been watching the show you guys
know i've been saying the words since
day one i think that they were going to
win the championships when they were
over plus 800 but
i want to talk about a team that i'm
willing to throw some money online i'm
willing to sprinkle
when the trade went down
i was on record saying brooklyn won the
trade and i absolutely to this day think
that brooklyn in the long term won that
james harden trade i do think brooklyn
won
but james harden joe l and b
that is going to be a problem for the
east live that's going to be an absolute
problem for the east and uh they're
sitting that plus 750 they were at plus
1100 when the trade first went down it's
down to plus 750 and i think it's moving
for a reason and i'm
i'm going to rock with that i'm going to
sprinkle something on that sprinkle
something on the warriors and we're
gonna try to get rich here but uh
let me
get into the comments
let me get into these comments liv cause
i gotta see what they are talking about
and i see ad when l says warriors all
day shout out to you ad when you are
walking away with a hoodie b wilson he
had a hoodie already but he has a great
take and says the cavs are the underdog
i like that i do like that uh
shout out to you b wilson you are
walking away with a hoodie you already
have one uh tonyville is in the comments
tonyville in the comments uh he says
celtics shout out to you tonyville
you're walking away oh the comments are
all over the place live the comments are
all over the place but i got a hot topic
yeah i got a hot topic for you
you saw right in those title odds those
los angeles lakers are currently at plus
4200
is it possible liv is it possible that
they don't even make the playoffs this
year
very possible i don't think that they
are making the playoffs this year i mean
a.d
god bless him can't stay healthy
there is really no true chemistry with
this team right now i think the
expectation was getting westbrook um
having a.d having lebron you know having
all these different pieces was going to
be the answer uh for this lakers team
this season and russell westbrook has
not really been the glue that's holding
them together i think as a point guard
that's kind of your role to be that
facilitator and you don't know what
you're going to get from him on any
given night so
kind of a letdown for me with this
lakers team right now
i was in cleveland i heard all the
chatter i heard all the gossip and
cleveland is convinced that lebron james
is coming home they are convinced after
he made the statement that he wants to
play with brony before he retires that
he is headed back home to cleveland and
i gotta tell you when he walked out on
that court and he threw his powder
you could see it in his eyes he was like
a kid on christmas being back in
cleveland you could tell was where he
felt it felt like home to him and i
could see that uh i just don't feel like
he's all the way locked in with this
lakers team this season and that's fine
um doesn't take away from how talented
he is but
i don't see it with the lakers this year
i don't see the spark i don't see the
chemistry
they're just not doing it for me so i
definitely think there's a chance they
don't make the playoffs this season
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me if they think it's possible
those los angeles lakers
make the postseason believe i am right
there with you those are the odds right
there and
live
i'll be honest
i'm gonna say yes i'm gonna say yes and
i am leaning on
that man
lebron james we've seen it year in and
year out and i think that lebron
will
find a way to get to the postseason
now liv
i want to be on record saying this
it is going to be very very challenging
for a team
to beat lebron james in the playoffs so
watch out for those los angeles lakers
if they do make the playoffs we got
russell westbrook lebron james maybe a.d
hopefully he comes back but those are
three superstars on one team in the
playoffs adjustments will be made in the
playoffs they let people play they let
the guys play a little bit more
in the playoffs and we talking lebron
james so
i'm not betting it i'll be honest i'm
not betting it
but
you guys can think about it think about
it you lakers fans you know that's what
you guys like to do it's better on those
lakers but think about it
and uh
i'll see you on the other side but i'm
in the comments live i am in the
comments
gotta give away some hoodies gotta to
give away some hoodies i see
leaky two says lakers is making the
playoffs shout out to you you're walking
away with a hoodie the unknown laker
says lakers limp in cause they still got
bronze which i agree with they still do
have lebron james um
br baden says greg on record hey you
guys clipped this out i did say it but
liv uh we reached we reached the end we
reached the end of the show thanks
everybody thank you to everybody that is
here watching for tapping into the group
chat presented by fanduel remember what
you guys learned today the three by two
is a lot the three by two parlay is a
lot get on fanduel and tell our br
betting same game
parlays we'll be back
next thursday giving out more hoodies
more jerseys and more locks if you
want a hoodie today we will
dm you alongside live moods i'm greg
ivory we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you